that's crazy man well you know what's
interesting is how like you know what's
interesting is like how we view like
like foreign relations and like visitors
people visiting from other countries in
America and how they do in other
countries like when I was in like I was
in China week ago and they don't [ __ ]
you want to try you were in China week
ago hung high yeah you really a channel
oh yeah oh and they do not do I saw make
is no see huh and feed it to a cat you
know I saw a guy pick a booger out of
the theater Shanghai for that yeah I
know you can see out here locally but
not everybody has you know experience my
boogers that circus Olli that everybody
has that right here in the yeah but what
happened was dude they you cannot get a
citizenship they're like if you're not
Chinese they don't give a [ __ ] they're
not like yeah come here come spent they
don't so many other countries are like
[ __ ] you get the [ __ ] out of here you
know yeah it's like what you want to
live there though it's a beautiful place
yeah you be bored so quick though man
but you're you're thinking China just
looks one certain way city life and
country life okay look do you think that
New York is the same as Nebraska do you
you don't remember your days on the corn
[Laughter]
farmer on the corn yeah dude but it it's
just interesting how like you go to some
of these other places and they don't
[ __ ] want us there it's like we're
not even welcome and I know it's like
lead by example you know welcome
everybody yeah but at the same time
sometimes it's like at least let
everybody let people know that these
people are [ __ ] you know like you're
not really welcome in these places yeah
you know in France they're the rude and
so I understand welcoming people to
America yeah but I don't understand
sometimes saying okay let's turn America
into China so that China can feel
welcome here you know people come here
because they want to be in America like
they want to be [ __ ] American you
know or cuz they want like American [ __ ]
you know yeah nobody
doesn't want to move here from Sweden
and have it be Sweden you know why
because they are they being [ __ ]
Sweden you know sometimes it's just like
I don't know this one makes you mad that
you shouldn't be a politician should
have a I don't know who dude I sometimes
I don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
talking you you said
city life and country life dude they're
two different things yeah and it would
be the same in China okay
name a country in China a country in
China yeah a country in Chinese I get
this guy that he's like he's thinking -
yeah that's a cologne there without a
base there annoys now they belong to
China you see but it's a Island of China
it's a city where people nobody in here
knows anything is what I'm starting to
gather we don't know anything really
don't we don't we don't know a lot about
a lot that's why we have people on to
teach us we don't well you shouldn't
have me
[Music]